[Music]
nighty night
have a good sleep don't let the bedbugs
imagine your bedroom infested with these
tiny bugs but what if
they were the same size as us
how much blood would a giant bedbug
drink
how fast could they take over the world
and could bright colors save you from an
attack
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if bed bugs were the size of humans
since the early 2000s bed bug
infestations
have been increasing in countries like
the united states
canada and the united kingdom the bites
themselves are not
harmful but they can be annoying and
itchy imagine if the bed bugs
were the same size as we are
that would be a scene straight out of a
horror movie
would they still be able to hide away
the average bedbug cymex lacularius or
cymex hemeterras are about seven
millimeters long the size of an apple
seed
they're flat and round with a reddish
brown color
now supersize one of these bugs to
human size and oh boy would it be scary
they'd be 200 times bigger
and even more terrifying a bed bug
can consume seven times its weight in
blood
our bodies contain about five liters of
blood
and a human sized bed bug weighing
79 kilograms could consume brace
yourself
[Music]
553g kilograms of blood
in one meal yeah it would need to suck
110 people dry
and these bloodsuckers would only get
bigger after
gorging themselves on your blood a giant
bed bug
would rapidly expand to 2.6
meters it would be a vampire
and a bug apocalypse rolled into one
you know to run and hide from these bugs
you need to be healthy and that's where
ritual comes in
ritual provides a vegan-friendly
multivitamin with high quality nutrients
free of gmos ritual vitamins don't have
any extra sugars
allergens synthetic fillers or
artificial coloring they taste great and
are easy to take every day perfect for a
bug apocalypse where you need to fight
to stay alive
ritual vitamins make all their nutrients
fully traceable so you
can see where they came from and to make
your life that
extra step easier ritual will deliver to
your door
every month with free shipping you can
start pause or cancel your subscription
anytime you want and
in the first month if you think ritual
isn't for you they'll refund your first
order
how great is that and ritual is offering
what if viewers
10 off for your first three months just
visit
ritual.com science that's rit
ual.com science to start your ritual
today
maybe i should take one right now just
in case those bed bugs show up and i
need to run away yeah giant bugs that
can
suck all your blood for breakfast would
be
deadly hunters and we'd be their prey
you know it's bad enough that these bugs
are human sized but
do you know how fast they would multiply
according to phil kohler of the
university of florida
one pair of bed bugs can become 35
000 in just 10 weeks which means that in
just a few weeks
a bed bug infestation could explode
exponentially we would be overrun with
giant biting bugs in no time
and you probably wouldn't even feel it
when they attacked you bed bugs saliva
contains an anesthetic so their bites
are nearly painless what did you do
to fight back you could fight them
toe to toe and that would be all too
horrifying
however we can learn from tiny bed bugs
a 2016 study found they don't like the
colors
yellow or green and they much prefer
red or black to hide in so
having brightly colored sheets or walls
might deter them
or defend you against the giant bugs
if you'd rather fight them then good old
fire and ice might be your best options
get yourself a flame thrower and you're
good to go
or you could trap them in one of those
storage freezers to kill them
[Music]
so it looks like it would probably be an
all-out war
with humans vs bedbugs and
we're waging that war right now with
real bed bugs
yeah they're much smaller but that means
they can easily hide from us
and they can cause issues like irregular
heartbeats due to blood loss
but hey if you think that giant bed bugs
would be terrifying
what if godzilla was real
well that's a story for another
what if